[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt wir
haben gerade richtig lust auf burger
unsere bürger bei uns also die brötchen
haben wir schon gemacht da könnt ihr
euch meinen grundrezept anschauen denn
ich habe einmal ein grundrezept für ganz
klassische bürgerbus und dann noch ein
grundrezept gemacht für diese hohen
fluffigen mega luftigen burger bands die
sie nämlich in so eine bürgerin gebacken
da könnt ihr die schau die haben wir
bereits vorbereitet und werden jetzt
eine richtig leckere teriyaki soße dazu
machen
die bereiten als erstes zog die kammer
auch super vorbereiten und auch wirklich
im kühlschrank lagern da passiert nichts
dann habt ihr immer was auf vorrat
danach werden wir noch die partie selber
herstellen und den sommer bürger richtig
lecker belegen
wir gucken mal ob wir heute alles fertig
kriegen wir morgen noch ein teil was
hier stinkt das ist der es sich eher
wach ich liebte ehrlichkeit hier also
für die teriyaki soße und du mit deiner
verstopften nase du riechst das ja ja da
muss es ja richtig stinkt okay für die
taxis verwenden wir 200 gramm soja sauce
100 gramm frauen und 20 gramm stärke 3
knoblauchzehen 30 gramm irgendwo einen
esslöffel sesamöl und 40 gramm reis es
ich konsumiere wir geben jetzt schon hat
in braun und zucker hier rein und du
darfst den karamellisieren
ich glaube du weißt wie das geht das
heißt auf den herd und dann mittel hohe
hitze nicht rühren sondern einfach nur
langsam schmelzen und karamellisieren
lassen genau unser vergeblich neuen
samira hat jetzt auf fünf gestellt fünf
oder sechs es passt ich kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit schon mal die
knoblauchzehen und den ingwer hacken
[Musik]
also etwas grad menschen gemalt und der
einzige der einen bauch hat ist der papa
der papa
und jetzt einfach lassen nicht früher du
kannst auch mal kurz was machen
es war darfst du hier die stärke
einrühren
als ich nehme die sojasauce jetzt
stärken die sojasauce
da kann sie jetzt auch den essig dazu
geben der so ein bisschen stinkt dann
nimmt er reißt sich oder apfelessig zum
beispiel reis es wäre natürlich
japanisch und jetzt verrühren ja ich
gebe es immer hierüber nicht rühren
nicht denn ingo und die knoblauchzehen
einfach auch hier mit rein
das jetzt hier super aus perfekt
geschmolzen
jetzt geben wir ein bisschen zur seite
weil jetzt kann es passieren dass es
vielleicht was spritzt und karamell ist
sehr sehr heiß also da wirklich
aufpassen
am besten auch als prozent herunter
stellen und wirklich sehr vorsichtig
arbeiten los damit ablöschen und das ist
völlig normal wenn es ein dicker
karamell platz entsteht so wie hier
denn der zucker wird jetzt durch die
kalte soßen natürlich erstmal fest aber
das gleicht somit war die soße einfach
nur noch im moment warte bis die
gefährliche situation beweist jetzt
gerne wieder den herd bisserl
hochschalten dass es wirklich auch schon
auf kocht mit pfeffer abschmecken und
dann die sauce aufkochen lassen und etwa
vier minuten dann wieder bei mittlerer
hitze köcheln lassen und abschmecken
also mal gucken salz pfeffer ob alles
passt natürlich ist eine terry yake so
sind da muss ja der zucker rein weil man
eben dieses sojasauce ausgleicht und es
ist wirklich nichts außer die sich
perfekt haltbar machen lässt eben durch
den zucker und ich sage noch einmal
gleich mit einer soße oder auch eine
soße für was anderes also das ist so ein
grundrezept hast gemalt mit kopfhörern
ist es der joshua mit kopfhörern
[Musik]
ich glaube wir müssen tatsächlich damit
die soße nicht zu dick wird bisschen was
auch für 50 milliliter
jetzt ist die soße perfekt ich habe sie
nur ein bisschen verfeinert mit wasser
und zucker ich schreibe euch einfach die
genaue menge gegen die app dann wirst du
doch bescheid
und jetzt werde ich sie hier ein
bisschen spät allerdings glaube ich die
für die flasche das ganze sieben damit
ich praktisch die stückchen nicht drin
habt ihr könnt ja auch parieren aber
muss nicht
war sie zu schwarz
mega super aus und dann mache ich noch
dass so die kinder version weil die
kinder
ich glaube wenn ich dir jetzt fragt
wollt ihr mit stückchen oder ohne er
ohne und virtuos lasse ich aber die
stück sind drin
da gebe ich dir einfach wieder zurück
knobloch sehr mag die gebe ich jetzt
hier rein und kann jetzt beide gläser
verschließen die soße aufbewahren und
diese sich auch mehrere wochen haltbar
denn ich habe zucker als
konservierungsmittel und habe die soße
eingekocht jetzt stelle ich die kurz weg
und kann schon mal das fleisch
vorbereiten da habe ich jetzt einen
rindfleisch bereits gekauft in großer
menge wert kurz hackfleisch daraus
zubereiten und daneben die pettys formen
[Musik]
ich habe ich mein rindfleisch wie gesagt
ich habe ein bisschen mehr denn ich
frage auch immer gerne was wichtig ist
im prinzip nur dass er es lange
schneidet nicht in würfel damit der
fleischwolf einfach das fleisch schön
greifen kann um die spirale wickelt und
fertig da muss man auch fast nicht nach
stopfen
[Musik]
das fleisch wird es noch kurz
durchgeknetet damit sich einfach ist mit
dem fleisch verbindet das reicht schon
und ich mache es ganz jetzt hier mit
einer burger presse geht für mich
einfacher ihr könnt aber auch einfach
eine portion nehmen zu kugeln formen und
flach drücken
aber wenn ihr pettys macht und sie
wirklich gleichmäßig geformt sind dann
sind sie natürlich auch gleichmäßig gar
also ich habe wie gesagt eine burger
presse die ich endlich auch mal zum
bürger machen benutze ansonsten immer
nur so für torten und ich mache jetzt
glaube ich kingsize 180 ja das heißt
bisschen back trance brett drauf dass
ella kindes damen wiesn 886 ist auch
okay aber weder das augenmaß haben wir
es wieder da und jetzt drücken
nach dem fest drücken mit einer palette
zum beispiel oder einem stumpfen messer
am rand entlang fahren dann löst sich
von ganz alleine
ich gehe jetzt hier auf sondern gleich
was wirklich auch schön ins gefrierfach
passt mit einer back folie der schon
extra diese wirkung bringen eben auch
damit fleisch später beim grillen eben
sich nicht so zusammenzieht und schön
durch gab sorgt das mache ich jetzt und
frier sie dann ein denn gerade das
einfrieren des wirklichen super tipp
damit die partie später eben auch ich
auf dem grill kleben das heißt für mich
ich habe jetzt die soße vorbereitet ich
habe meine burger politischen
vorbereitet und den rest mache ich dann
aber erst morgen
denn die können jetzt einfach über nacht
in einen gefrierschrank aber eine stunde
oder zwei reichen auch und dann machen
wir morgen nämlich unsere subotic
ich habe eine kugel geformt dann
verteile ich das hier so eindrücklich es
fest
ihr könnt so einen dünnen berger machen
mit 120 gramm oder king 280 com
aber das sieht perfekt aus
[Musik]
ich sehe große menge hat natürlich einen
vorteil
ich mache jetzt einfach alle fertig und
wenn sie dann gefroren sind kann es
nämlich verpacken und habe einfach für
den nächsten grillenberger events schon
mal meine pettys fertig und wenn ihr
dann auch bald schon eingefroren habt
ist das burger grillten wirklich ein
kinderspiel
also wenn ihr platz im griff gehabt
[Musik]
und jetzt so einfriert und wenn sie
gekommen sind werde ich sie einfach in
eine schüssel verpacken kann sie dort
übereinander stapeln und dann kann man
sie morgen grillen
heute ist der nächste tag heute gibt's
burger und ich hab jetzt schon alles
vorbereitet schaut mal die pettys habe
ich wirklich gut eingefroren jetzt habe
ich sie einfach luftdicht verpackt die
habe ich im gefrierschrank falls wir
einfach die nächsten wochen wieder
bürger haben möchten habe ich sie schon
bereit
ich habe ich meine brötchen und da
möchte ich noch kurz dazu sagen hier
habe ich jetzt diese hohen brötchen mit
150 gramm hier die flachere mit 100
gramm also es war wirklich so 150 gramm
da bekommt ihr aus dem grundrezept zwölf
stück raus wenn ihr 100 gramm macht sind
etwa 18 stück und ich finde gerade für
sanierer und eggers in den flacheren
etwas besser vor allem zum essen und für
murat für und die erwachsen waren schon
die hohen ganz gut nur dass er das zur
info ist ich werde jetzt hier dazu noch
salat servieren habe noch rote zwiebeln
und eine annahmestelle ich habe mir
gedacht so sommer burger was pasta dazu
irgendwie die ananas teriyaki soße ich
glaube das wird ganz gut wir probieren
später einfach und ich haben anders auf
den burger gegessen aber in meiner
vorstellung
es ist ganz gut ja was mache ich zuerst
spielt eigentlich gleichzeitig erhöhte
jetzt schon mal angefangen denn draußen
regnet wir gehen leider nicht auf den
grill
wir stinken die küche zu jetzt kann ich
hier meine grillplatte kurz einfetten
wer nämlich jetzt die den streifen weil
ich einfach super gerne diese streifen
habe so
und kann jetzt schon mal das brot auch
halbieren
das ist bereit ist
guck mal wie locker und leicht uns super
flu wichtig geworden sind
die ananas schild die entweder mit einem
messer oder mit einem ananas scheler und
schneider finde ich einfach weil ich so
direkt zwei arbeitsschritte in einem
habe und man kann hier auch ablesen wie
viele scheiben es sind und wenn ihr
nicht bis ganz nach unten dreht könnt
ihr es raus nehmen und habe sogar noch
einen cocktail welcher also eher langsam
ira die dänen für dich dann einfach
wasser ein
und dann nehmen sie strohhalm und
schlürfen hier ihre ananas wasser raus
das ist schon ganz cool für die kids das
glaub ich bewahrte denen auch für später
ja ich fange jetzt hier auch schon mal
an nebenher die fleisch pettys zu
grillen
denn wir sind ja wirklich gleichwertig
und ärzte wenden wenn sozusagen die
erste seite gut gegrillt ich hier lese
ich dass da hinten jetzt ab ganz
herausnehmen
ich will jetzt schreiben haben also
schneide ich einfach her wo dieses ende
ist einmal von oben nach unten durch und
habe jetzt praktisch meine
ananasscheiben was man übrigens auch
wunderbar machen kann ich nehme jetzt
mal noch eine ananas schneidet hier oben
entdecken weg und scheele und schneidet
sie in einem zug
dann entferne ich hier oben den griff
ich habe ich jetzt noch ein gefäß direkt
mit dabei und setzt jetzt hier
diese scheibe auf ich kann nämlich
direkt die ananasstückchen dann
praktisch hier eingeben
kannst du doch auffallen lassen die
ananas spirale und direkt die stückchen
schneiden hier decken mit dem stiel und
dann einfach nur noch sanft drücken
perfekt und dann habt ihr einfach eure
ananasstückchen die drücke ich hier noch
kurz durch und hab sie direkt hier den
stil entfernt in der praktischen
aufbewahrungs dose und könnt eure
anderen stückchen einfach aufbewahren
das mache ich vor allem ganz oft wenn
die anderen noch so kurz vorm abgang ist
als ich merkte ich habe schon wieder zu
viel anderes gekauft und ich benutze
gerade nicht dann mache ich das so ich
kann sie entweder einfrieren oder ella
die ist total gerne anders und habe es
einfach schön verstaut im kühlschrank
und sie ist wirklich einsatzbereit
zwiebeln ich habe jetzt die rote
zwiebeln das schneide ich jetzt mal als
dicke scheiben runter ihr könnt aber
auch dünne schneiden
[Musik]
die sind jetzt perfekt ich schlage die
jetzt einfach nur ganz kurz hier wird
zum warmhalten sozusagen jetzt grill ich
noch die ananasscheiben ich mache halt
erstmal drei bohrer fertig
kann mich brot schon mal erhitzen und
gleich belegen was sie zur therapie soße
noch sagen muss ich musste noch mal
heißes wasser einfüllen denn die wurde
über nacht völlig es abkühlen echt
richtig fest aber wie gesagt schreibe
ich euch da die genaue menge einfach
rein
denn ich habe mich damit gerechnet dass
es so fest wird so richtig sonne und
dann geht es gleich los los du sagst man
gleich probieren
ich bin schon gespannt ich auch denn
ananas auf dem burger hatte ich noch nie
aber anders auf der pizza lewis früher
hatte ich auch ich bin so ein bisschen
davon abgekommen aber eigentlich ja
eigentlich ganz gut ok ich dann da gibt
es glaube ich so menschen die es lieben
und menschen die sagen hab ich nicht
scheiden sich auch die geister ob man
das darf über mich da ich glaube auch
dass das fleisch ist doch schon mal raus
damit das brot platz findet
wasserburger grill ist schon wenn man
gut vorbereitet schon eigentlich ganz
natürlich man kann jetzt die große
platte nehmen da passen natürlich viel
mehr drauf aber ich wollte jetzt so für
uns hier 3413 hier nicht so viel machen
[Musik]
die zwiebeln anbraten oder nicht also
ich bin eigentlich immer fan von
geschmorten zwiebeln ich auch ach so ein
paar
du kannst ja kurz anschwitzen ja die
spitzt sich kurz mit
ok
ich würde sagen 'ich packe zählt area
die soße drauf
lasst den lkw vorbeifahren
mit etwas salat
ich bin fan von nochmal soße denn das
fleisch ist wie ihr wisst nicht gewusst
dass heißt es fleisch schmeckt einfach
nur nach rindfleisch dann das fleisch
ich würde zum bisschen pfeffer darüber
geben
für den geschmack salz lass ich mal weg
denn die terrasse ist ja wirklich schön
würze die zwiebelchen die könnt ihr
gerne noch länger sporn oder ebenso
lassen
ich habe so eine zweite pfanne praktisch
hinstellen müssen die flache pfanne für
die brötchen für das für die zwiebelchen
aber ich wollte jetzt einfach ein
bisschen sparsam sind und noch mal final
etwas teriyaki und heute die premiere
ananas habe ich was vergessen nein das
warme brötchen eu allah und weil man so
einen burger so eigentlich auch nicht
wirklich servieren präsentieren kann
kommt noch ein bürger spiels rein wenn
ihr normale bürger macht nimmt dir diese
bürger spitze wenn ihr deluxe bürger
macht nimmt ihr diese ich glaube heute
feiert die st und dann fällt auch nicht
auseinander besamen tisch landet also
das ist unser burger josch ich würde
sagen wir zwei probieren okay und ich
finde es auch so ein burger nur wie bei
hans im glück dass entweder ist man ihn
aus der hand und es ist einfach
furchtbar egal wenn man danach aussieht
oder erst mit messer und gabel
egal wie ihr möchtet
[Musik]
berger wäre ich bin hier partner
ich bin sehr gespannt ich auch vor allem
soße süßes fleisch salat röckchen also
durch eine kombination die hat man auch
in bürgerrechte rechts noch nach nur so
habe ich noch nie probiert so was mich
zeigen also die war hans im glück wenn
du noch glücklicher werden willst
problem einem bürger aus
aber ich möchte auch dass kelly heißt
also ich mache jetzt studiert jetzt
gegessen so auf der hand ja schon
sie haben auch erst am abend gemacht
haben aus der hand gegessen aber wir
können jetzt nicht zusammenreißen
das ist komisch vor allem muss ich sagen
ich hatte gerade schon angst davor als
sie gesagt das ist schon probieren und
dass ich mich jetzt so dumm anstellen
muss unterberger daher wie breit ist
echt gegen wieder von osten her also
dann man das mit ganzem herzen
also ich als damals hätte sowieso den
deckel mit der unternehmen
essen bei einem bürger und dann und da
einfach noch mal belegen aber müssten
sie anteilig das brot wenn bretter
gestellt
aber wenn man halt so wurde schon ist
sie nicht essen kann dann ja so ein
bisschen
ich bin fan von ananas auf burger
die süße super dann die therapie so mega
gut dazu das ist ein perfekter bürger
für so ein sommerabend so weiter geht
haben wir bis heute regen bitte leider
habe ich aber noch wahr haben uns die
soße auf die brötchen auf und das
fleisch auf ich hab noch die soße drauf
habe mega gut
lecker also ich muss sagen wer kommt in
die top 3 der besten bürgerliche
gegessen hast meinen arsch männer pagano
berger verpasst dieser dieser oder
dieser ich weiß nicht wo ihre link
graner pagano burger das war so von alex
das dashboard sagt iris ich kann nichts
mehr essen ich habe den büschelberger
der welt gegessen war der grad an
der gehört der väter auch dazu aber der
stress und der birkenwald jetzt könnt
ihr hier jungs alles schön verhängten
alle bürger noch platz im bild warum es
das magazin will für uns vielleicht hier
in der mitte
also viel spaß beim nachmachen
probiert's unbedingt aus ich liebe den
burger mit ananas und ich bin so froh
dass ich heute nur ganz wenig gefragt ob
denn jetzt gibt es keine chance und
vieles mehr
die so schlecht ja jetzt schon
ich glaube ich muss ihn einmal auch ins
bild drehen wir jetzt aussieht weiß dass
man also da ist wirklich grandios
als ob dies nicht bis zum nächsten noch
nicht denn fertig ist ja nimmt das ganze
brett da passt dann nämlich doch ein
zweiter und ein dritter drauf das ist
ganz gut kamen gleich zurück zu kehren
und michael drews unterbrochen für zehn
minuten und handeln ist leider keine
videos mehr im tennis
[Musik]